[Music]
welcome to the writing tomatoes lab
critics edition this is the first
installment in a new series of panels
virtual and in person as well as
features and workshops that will focus
on engaging conversations and advice for
aspiring critics
breaking into the industry can be a
complex process and writing tomatoes is
proud to collaborate with experts in the
field to provide guidance and tools for
the next generation of critics
new installments in this series will
publish quarterly on rottentomatoes.com
and be available under the resources tab
i'm sharonda williams producer and host
of the youtube channel pear weight and
our conversation today will focus on the
ins and outs of self-publishing we're so
excited to have the following guests
with us today eric anderson is the
founder and editor-in-chief of awards
watch and a self-professed lover of all
things oscars robert daniels is a
freelance film critic who has written
for roger eber.com the new york times
vulture and polygon he is also the
founder of eight one two film reviews le
lai is the founder and editor-in-chief
of mediaversityreviews a publication
that scores films and tv series on
metrics of diversity kristin lopez is
the tv editor at indy wire as well as a
disabled critic and essayist outside of
indy wire her work has appeared in
variety forbes and mtv so when we get
started i want to ask all of the
panelists a question today
self-publishing plays an important role
in giving aspiring critics a place to
start but there's still a stigma around
reviewing on your own website why should
people persist in creating their own
platform despite industry bias and
robert i'll kick it off to you first
knew you're going to come to me first
[Laughter]
well at least i would say i think one of
the great things about when i first
started self-publishing was the ability
to experiment right you wanna
you're first starting out experiment
with your writing experiment with your
voice um and then also self-publishing
gives you the opportunity to write about
what you wanna write about right if you
start publishing for a larger site then
basically on assignment a lot
but
you know they're if you're into short
films if you're into
more international cinema um whatever it
may be you know
it's a lot easier to try to publish it
on your own
and then go to a site you know a bigger
publication that might not have the
resources or the want to cover it um so
being able to self-publish really just
gives you the chance to
explore what you want to explore whether
it's yourself or the works that you want
to
go over thank you and how about you
i would say uh
rather than in spite of the industry do
it because of the industry itself um if
you're not seeing
the the type of
people that you want to see
doing reviews and doing coverage
you're that you're that person that
if you're looking around for for
somebody else to do it look look at
yourself you're you are that person to
do it
um and and i think that can kick-start
not only your own
uh career but
absolutely inspire people around you
because
it's not it isn't easy to be
a first person you know to do something
if you don't see
uh
the the type of representation that you
want to
to see and you are that person it's
really hard to make that that big first
step
because you know you might not get seen
enough or
you might be worried about
criticism coming to you but if
if if you want it then then you are that
person and you'll inspire other people
without question emily
yeah definitely adding to both what
robert and eric just said it's
definitely a great opportunity to
explore and experiment
and it's absolutely perfect for
for finding gaps that already exist in
criticism and then you know filling
those in yourself
that's definitely
why i even started in the first place my
background's not as a writer so i really
only got into it purely because i felt
like there was something missing and i
and i looked around and i wanted someone
else to do it nobody else was doing it
so
i think that's a great reason to start
your own website is just to be able to
plug the gaps that are in the industry
and kirsten
yeah for me it's a bit of a different
scenario
you know when i was when i was
self-publishing it was more as a outlet
for
what little relaxation i think us as
writers can find uh you know so often
we're assigned things to write about or
are trying to capitalize on the same
things that everybody else is writing
about so for me when i was running my
own website it was because i wanted to
talk about movies that i wasn't being
forced to talk about so i talked about
classic film it was something that i
watched a lot of in my free time and
noticed that a lot of people weren't
talking about it um so so for me it was
kind of a way of getting out of the
critic mindset and just having a fun
outlet to do what i wanted
you